معنا من جد الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس مركز الخليج للابحاث سيد عبد العزيز
مرحبا بك معنا كيف تتابع هذه التطورات
المتسارعه في البحر الاحمر وما الانعكاسات
الجيوسياسيه لهذا التوتر متصاعد على الامن
الملاحي في منطقه البحر
الاحمر مساء الخير لك ومشاهدين الجزيره في
كل مكان الحقيقه هذا ينم ان هنالك تقصير
دولي فيما يتعلق بتطبيق قانون البحار فيما
يتعلق بامن البحار هذه ليست المره الاولى
ويعني المشكله الكبيره التي تكمن في امن
الممرات المائيه والبحار بالنسبه لنا في
المنطقه شهدناها في حرب الناقلات في
الثمانينات خلال فتره الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه وشاهدناها في عمليات القرصنه
البحريه وشاهدناها في بدايه العمليات يعني
في لاعاده الشرعيه في اليمن ضد الحوثي
فهذه يعني ليست جديده بالنسبه لنا و لكن
يبدو ما يختلف هنا ان المصالح ا والاهتمام
الامريكي اخذ منحى اخر يختلف عن ما كان
عليه في السابق المملكه استشعرت اهميه الب
البحر الاحمر والتهديدات الموجوده فيه
ولذلك كانت هي والدول المتشاطئة
وتمت المباركه لمشاركه ثمانيه دول
التداعيات بالتاكيد لها تداعيات كبيره
سواء على المستوى الاقتصادي وعلى المستوى
الاستراتيجي على المستوى الاقتصادي هنالك
تاثيرات فيما يتعلق باسعار الشحن التامين
زياده كلفه البضائع استهلاك الطاقه
والوقود المده الزمنيه باستخدام راس
الرجاء الصالح بد من البحر الاحمر وهذا
يزود في المسافه من 6 الى 12 يوم وبعض
الاحيان 14 يوم تعتمد على حسب الحملات
السفن وقدرتها ونوعيه البضائع التي تحملها
ايضا هنالك كلفه استراتيجيه على فكره فاذا
كانت الدول مصدره للنفط وتعرضت موانعها
لتهديدات ولا تتمكن من تصدير الطاقه فهي
تتعرض لخسائر كبيره وت تهدد والدول
المستورده للطاقه ايضا تتعرض لنوع من
التهديد لانه ما يمر عبر البحر الاحمر
اكثر من 9 ملايين برميل في اليوم وما
يقارب 16% تقريبا من حجم التجاره العالميه
فهذا يمث ثل تهديد حقيقي ومهم في المنطقه
ا طيب دكتور عبد العزيز ما قراءتكم
الاستراتيجيه كخبير متابع لقضايا امن
المنطقه لمستقبل هذا التصعيد في ضوء مواقف
الاطراف المعلنه سواء من الولايات المتحده
وايضا من جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين يعني انصار الله هي ليست دوله
حتى تستطيع ان تحاربها وان تتعامل معها
انت تعرفي هنالك ثلاثه مراحل مهمه المرحله
الاولى هي الردع ويبدو ان الحوثي لم تتمكن
الولايات المتحده او الدول الغربيه في
تطبيق الردع كما يعني يجب ان يكون لان
هنالك درس سابق ايران كانت في السابق تقوم
بعمليات مشابهه لهذه العمليات ولم يتم
ردعها او يعني التاكيد على قضيه الردع
مرحله ما بعد الردع هو الدفاع وهذه
المرحله التي نحن فيها الان الولايات
المتحده تتصدى لعمليات وصواريخ ودرون تطلق
ولذلك هي هذه المرحله الدفاعيه وليست
معالجه مصدر التهديد نفسه بمعنى انه
الحوثي لا يمتلك قدرات بحريه واسطول بحري
وانما معظم هذه القدرات موجوده في داخل
الاراضي اليمنيه فالسؤال هو هل سوف ننتقل
لمرحله ثالثه وهي المرحله الهجوميه التي
تقوم فيها الولايات المتحده او الدول
المتحالفه معه في هذا التحالف بتنفيذ
عمليات داخل الاراضي اليمنيه على مصادر
التهديد ومنبعها هنالك هذا ما زال سؤال
مطروح في المرحله هذه ما زلنا في مرحله
الدفاعيه وهي التي تتع عرض او وتحاول ان
تتصدى للدرون والصواريخ التي تطلق وبالنظر
دكتور عبد العزيز لاهميه الملاحه في
المنطقه المتشاطئة
غزه ليس جديد موضوع غزه هو بدا الان حينما
الحوثي اراد
ان يعني ينفذ التعليمات الايرانيه بالرغم
من انكار ايران لذلك بالقيام بعمليات
واطلاق صواريخ او درونات باستخدام الشواطئ
البحر الاحمر او محاوله العبور عبر
الاراضي السعوديه لكن هو السؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه له كيف يكون هنالك ا موقف دولي
المسؤوليه حمايه الممرات البحريه وال
المضائق هي مسؤوليه ميه دوليه ولها قانون
دولي ينظمها عبر الامم المتحده ما كان يجب
ان تقوم به الولايات المتحده هو استصدار
قرار من مجلس الامن حتى يكون هذا القرار
الزامي لجميع الدول وحتى تستطيع الدول ان
تتعاون معه لان هنالك بعض الدول التي
اعلنت موافقتها بالانضمام الى هذا التحالف
ربما تنسحب وربما لا ترغب ان تكون سفنها
البحريه وقطاعها البحريه تحت القياده
الامريكيه فهذا ايضا يعني سؤال راح يعني
ننظر في القريب العادل كيف سوف فيتم
التعامل معه لكن التهديد سوف يظل قائم
وموجود والمملكه يعني من سنوات طويله حذرت
من هذا التهديد ولذلك هي دعت وتم الاتفاق
في الرياض في عام 2020 لوجود الاتفاق بين
الدول المتشاطئة
هو تنسيقي وتعاون مشترك في تبادل
المعلومات يعني حمايه حرس الحدود منع
تهريب المخدرات منع التهريب البشري
الجريمه المنظمه لم تكن يعني موجهه
بالتحديد لبناء
قدرات ما يسمى بالني فورسز بمعنى القدرات
البحريه التي تستطيع ان تواجه اي عمليات
مشابهه لما يتم الان ا وما الانعكاسات
والمقالات التي يمكن ان تلقي بظلالها على
منظومتي الامن والرد
في المنطقه
و النقطه التي يمكن ان تنزلق فيها الامور
لتتصاعد
بصوره ربما تؤثر على الجميع وما يخشاه
الجميع يمكن ان
يحدث نقطه الانزلاق الحقيقيه هي اذا وصلنا
الى طريق مسدود اذا اذا لم يكن هنالك
نتيجه للردع ولم يكن هنالك نتيجه لايقاف
العمليات باستخدام يعني القدرات الدفاعيه
فمعناته سوف تضطر الولايات المتحده او
حلفاء او من معها بتنفيذ عمليات كل عمليه
سوف يكون لها رده فعل يعني احن شهدنا من
العام الماضي وقبله عمليات كان هنالك اكثر
من 16
عمليه للسفن بين السفن الايرانيه
والاسرائيليه اعتقادي 12 سفين 12 عمليه ضد
السفن الايرانيه وست عمليات ضد السفن
الاسرائيليه هذا الممر الهادئ اصبح يعني
هنالك توتر فيه واصبح في يعني توترات ايضا
في دوله مثل السودان تشل تقلبات و يشهد
مشاكل في الوقت الحاضر القرن الافريقي لم
يعد امن كما كان بالرغم من وجود قوه
مكافحه القرصنه اللي هي موجوده في في
المنطقه وبالرغم من وجود قواعد بحريه في
جبوتي العديد من الدول الخوف من التصعيد
هنا ان اذا دخلت في مواجهه مع الحوثي هل
سوف يتمدد هذا التوجه للدخول في مواجهه مع
ايران هل سوف تد لان ايران يعني قالت في
تصريحها وزير خارجيتها قال انه لن نمنع
الحوثيين من القيام باي عمليات بمعنى ان
هذا ضوء اخضر لهم بالقيام وايران في هذه
في الحقيقه هي اكدت على مركزيه القرار
بالنسبه لها هي هي تسيطر على حزب الله في
لبنان بان لا يقوم باعمال ولكنها يعني
تدعم الموقف الحوثي بالقيام باعمال وتحرك
الحشد الشعبي او الجماعه الاسلاميه
الجديده المقاومه الاسلاميه في في العراق
فهي اكدت على انها ما زال لها دور في
مركزيه قرارها في توجيه كل هذه الجماعات
في المنطقه هذا التصعيد لو اخذ موقع فيما
يتعلق بال القوات الامريكيه مع الحوثيين
وتمدد الى ردود فعل من قبل ايران ربما
نشهد توتر اعلى في المنطقه ا شكرا لك من
جده الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث